i have here
pipe of sorts i blowing air here and the
air current comes out through the spout
just so that you are convinced the air
is coming out watch
the air is coming out okay now
i'm going to
put this very light
ball
just above the spout okay and blow on it
the upward streaming air is supporting
the weight of the ball so that it's in
levitation is floating in in the middle
of the air so far so good but now
i can support it completely off the
vertical
let's see if i can do it in the other
direction too
did you see that
while it's off the vertical the
ball is spinning
this phenomenon has to do with all sorts
of questions a whole range of questions
that are often discussed in popular
literature and the technical literature
and has to do with for example how a
plane flies now the usual explanation is
that it's bernoulli's theorem that's the
technical term that people always invoke
and it's supposed to say that if you
have a flow of fluid
water what have you the
sum of
density times velocity squared over two
so speed squared plus
the pressure is supposed to be constant
so if there's a large speed there's more
pressure and if there's a large pressure
there's more speed and they'll say
they'll have you believe that well
there's fast airflow on this side
and there's slow airflow on this side so
the fast side has a low pressure and the
slow side has a high pressure so the
high pressure region is pushing low
pressure region and so it's going to be
lifted in this direction fighting the
gravitational fall and they will say
that that's the same thing why
the airplane is flying now this is not
quite right
because bernie's theorem if you read the
actual proof and the statement and so on
says that for each streamline that is
the flow line of say fluid particle
that's true but you cannot apply it
automatically to different stream lines
and in this case there is a streamline
coming above the ball and then
streamline below the ball but these are
different stream lines you can't apply
bernoulli to both at the same time you
can't say well this stream line this
stream line they have the same kind of
constant no it's it's not implied in the
theorem there is another version
bernoulli which is called the time
dependent bernoulli for potential flow
which means that if there is no vortex
in the system you can apply bernoulli to
the entire fluid region but in this case
there's a lot of vortex you saw the
whole thing spinning so you cannot apply
bernoulli there either
so it's actually a nonce application you
can't use bernoulli to explain this so
what is happening is the question what
is really happening has to do with
something that is subtle but in some
sense even more primitive than bernoulli
you see when we do this
the air is streaming above the ball and
is being deflected along the ball like
this why does it deflect because the air
has to stick to the ball and you know
fluid is a continuum he doesn't want to
sort of not snap out and create a vacuum
so if there is a solid boundary for
example some body like this he wants to
go along the boundary of this thing
and that's why it gets deflected and
underneath it kind of goes like that
also so the long and short of it is that
the whole airflow comes in like this but
goes out like this so it curved
but whenever the trajectory of a moving
object curves for example fluid curves
there must be a force that's curving it
yeah and that force is being supplied by
the ball
because ball is leading the fluid around
this because the fluid wants to cohere
that's the technical term and wants to
go around the ball well action and
reaction if nature has produced one
effect he has to pay for it by having
the counter effect and the reaction is
from the fluid surrounding fluid air to
the ball and if the ball has supplied
this kind of force in order to deflect
the airflow the air has to supply the
counter force in order to lift the ball
so whenever there is a curvature of the
flow line that creates what we call the
pressure gradient if it's curving like
this the inner part has high pressure
and outer part has low pressure and
mathematically speaking it's really
related with the centrifugal force so
centrifugal force for speed v is like v
squared over r r is the sort of radius
of this curvature and that's actually
the pressure gradient that you're
creating so the again long and short
with is that because you have high
pressure region low pressure region it's
going to be lifted upward
the ball is providing this deflecting a
curving trajectory so the ambient fluid
has to apply a force which compensates
for that which is in this direction and
this is really an effect of a curving
trajectory of any kind so if you have a
curving trajectory for example the
radius of this curvature is r and it's
going at the speed v and it's going
around it turns out that there's a
centrifugal force which is like this and
let's say rho is the density and this is
the pressure gradient which increases as
you go from into out that's what the
name is so professor the
the bowl yes
turned the air around the corner like it
made the it made the air change
direction yes so the air gets its
revenge in a way doesn't it that's it if
you're going to do that then i'm going
to push you in the opposite direction
that's a very good language but for the
air to get its revenge it has to touch
the bowl like it has yes
so where is the air punching the bowl is
it from underneath or yes because it
can't pull it can it because it hasn't
got like no hooks or anything that can
pull with well it can pull because you
see the if you have air next to the ball
and the air leaves the ball
well if you can just freely leave the
ball it's going to leave a vacuum behind
but the fact of the matter is the fluid
next to the solid
doesn't want to create a vacuum it
doesn't want to cavitate it wants to
sort of cohere he wants to feel the
whole space with some substance so when
it's pulling away
by that very effect it's actually
pulling the solid as well and on the
molecular level it's clear what's
happening you know molecules are all
attracting each other all the air
molecules are kind of connected by
spring to to neighboring region and when
you pull the spring the spring you know
shrinks and then pulls the whole thing
in and similarly if you push these
springs get compressed and that's what
the pressure is so professor as a
mathematician and a physicist when
you're sitting on a plane flying to
japan and you look out the window and
you see the wing
in your head are you imagining the wing
being
pulled up by the air or pushed up by the
air well i think it's both you see the
wind is so designed that roughly
speaking the air comes in like this
sorry air comes in like this and goes
out like that so it's
current is it this trajectory is
deflected and that creates two effects
both of which are conspiring of course
that the air underneath is pushing
upward and the air above is pulling
that's a figurative way of speaking but
essentially again what's going on is
that pressure there's a pressure
difference and you have an effect from
high pressure agent low pressure region
you are pushing against each other by
the way pressure is everyone knows is
force divided by area
if you multiply top and bottom numerator
and denominator by length you get force
times length that's called work that's a
form of energy and area times length
that's volume so it's actually energy
per volume pressure is like potential
energy per volume and we're saying that
if you have a high pressure region
that's high potential energy region and
low potential energy region which is low
low pressure region then the stuff moves
is pushed from high pressure to low
pressure which is exactly the same thing
as if you have a say a slope like this
hill and a valley well the balls wants
to roll from high potential region to
the low potential region just rolls down
and gains some kinetic energy by doing
this so the pressure is acting like a
potential energy let's let's do the
spoon actually so
let's go yeah let's do the spoon because
i like your
language of the taking revenge that's
that's great that's wonderful
so you can do another home experiment to
see that whenever a fluid flow
curves
the trajectory of the fluid curves it
creates a pressure gradient difference
in pressure which sucks something in on
one side and pushes something out on the
other side as soon as the spoon touches
the water the water gets
deflected you see from a
straight vertical down to the side and
that has the effect of
pulling the spoon in do you see that
poof
and that's because if the water momentum
is changed from this to this
that means that somebody must be
providing a force from left to right and
the counter force is applied to the
spoon from right to left and that sucks
in the spoon from this side and if i
touch the spoon
the water with the spoon from this side
it's the opposite effect
[Music]
so you can feel that spoon maybe like a
wing yeah and that's essentially like
that um you know levitating ball but the
picture is seen sideways you see the
airflow was coming in like this and
going up like this and if you turn it by
90 degrees it's exactly the same picture
yeah
and this is the ball which is sucked in
the direction opposite to the
directional deviation of the fluid flow
you see there's a cup here and the
challenge is to just tuck the ball up
and then put it in the cup now that's of
course very very difficult to do so you
shouldn't do this in public
and because the chances of success are
very small